[Music]
your season starts your for you it
starts Thursday Wednesday a Wednesday
okay
how you feel you ready to go ready I'm
very ready yeah yeah I would think you'd
be excited I mentioned your dunking
ability which is already legendary for
such a young player and I if you'll
indulge me there's a a Kendrick Perkins
from Oklahoma Thunder you dunked on him
over him through him and I think we
should take a second and relive that
incredible moment
[Applause]
amazing my favorite thing I noticed this
when it happened is the reaction of this
guy in the crowd
it just people's minds were blown you
can show this Alan there's a guy in the
crowd who just watch this the camera
pushes in on him I want to know because
I will never experience that what when
you're when you're dunking like that
dude this time slow down do you hear
orchestral music
is there a bright light does anything
change it slows down a little bit
honestly it happens it happens fast but
it slows down and then when you come
down there's a teammate the one who
grabbed me yeah seems to always be in
the area like from the bench he like
punch me in the chest so hard after a
dunk I broke my sternum
that's a nice reward yeah I'm curious
like you you'd feel it's an incredible
feeling but I think if you're the player
if say Kendrick Perkins you don't want
to be the guy who got dunked on because
that clip gets shown 10,000 times on
ESPN over over over and over again yeah
we haven't talked more since then
[Laughter]
an emotional reunion
he comes out would you have to do that
for
what about much-discussed the faces that
you make while dunking you're not happy
with these faces they're not great they
I probably have some of the worst action
shots in the NBA you think so
oh absolutely our PR girls come down you
know have a sign action shots to get
onto fans and they're just like good
it's like you're trying to pull off this
superhuman stuff you can't be thinking
while you're doing that I mean it's not
even about smiling it's just about
making the worst possible faces well
let's take a quick no that's really not
good money okay it's either you see what
I mean now it's not good it's pretty
it's yeah it's not good but the dumps
are fantastic that's the important thing
with you that's the important thing